[Music]
I'm just curious probably it started a
lot of people here tonight from
California understand your you seem
happy about that yes you're excited
about it I asked for a reason because I
thought some news you may not like this
is true in a recent poll I couldn't
believe this in a recent poll California
was voted the least popular state in the
u.s. yeah but don't worry we are still
the most popular state in Mexico and who
watched the Republican debate last night
wasn't that something
Wow
audience seats 350 and that was one
person and he was lying just so he could
hear his woo in a bar later on line up
ladies I don't even know what I was
ruling well in last night's Republican
debate the candidates were asked to
describe themselves in one word that's
right Rick Santorum said courage Ron
Paul said consistent and Newt Gingrich
said bootylicious here makes me like him
now yeah two of the biggest topics at
last night's GOP debate were illegal
immigration and birth control
those were the two yeah and I think Ron
Paul got confused cuz he said that we
should build a fence around women and
pull out of Mexico
I got that strength you know who's still
riding high Adele Adele won all those
Grammys sure well and yeah now this is
the latest according to the latest
figures Adele's new album is being
downloaded an average of every 7 seconds
every 7 seconds yeah this is due to the
fact that every seven seconds someone's
getting dumped is the minute you can't
dump yeah I need that fast it's kind of
worrisome it's being reported that a
security breach at a popular porn site
has revealed users email addresses and
passwords yeah I just want to reiterate
to my wife that the user conan at
O'Brien com password I love TBS That's
not me okay it is me that's my porn site
I'm not in the porn i watch the porn
it's just a side of you watching porn
just you going
if you tune into that site it's me
watching and then who
[Applause]